The Joe Rogan Experience between sets I
went over to greenblatts to get a cup of
coffee in them with this screenplay
writer uh his name was Mark I forgot his
last name actually I'm sorry sorry Mark
anyway we're getting coffee and here
comes this guy you know Rick Rubin with
the beard the whole look and he's with
this little like heavy set guy all right
oh man here comes some [__] you know
and um he goes yeah can I can I you know
we soft spoke and can I speak with you a
minute and
I I do have a Brooklyn attitude I'll
admit it you know and I go yeah well
yeah what can I do for your power you
got to do another show you know and then
the guy Mark that's with me goes aren't
you Rick Rubin
and I'm looking at him I'm going who's
Rick he goes he basically created rap
and Rick goes yeah I uh I want to do an
album with you and I don't want to
bother you I'm going to go next door and
watch the second show you know because I
had to do another show and that's how me
and Rick met and we wound up doing Five
albums together hmm you know and we were
a great team together I mean you know
he's Rick Rubin and I mean sometimes we
would disagree but you can't get Rick
mad
he's an interesting cat well very
different human being right oh it's it's
you know
I say to Rick one time
you know when when dice rules that where
I do grease lightning that was dice
rules the album okay besides the movie
and um I go did they yeah I was at West
Westwood One radio or something like
that
and on the way back you know I say to
Rick I go did they put up all the
posters like you said they were gonna do
you know and he goes I suppose
and I'm looking at him
I go you're the boss don't you know
I told him to put it up
yeah like you can't get even if he
didn't like something on an album and
you know I could get heated you know I'm
that kind of personality I'm like I
don't give a [__] it's not your [__]
album
well then I suppose you'll do what you
like
don't you ever get mad didn't you ever
have a fight and he goes actually I
never had a fight
um I go you never got a punch in the
face
like he goes no I go well you're about
to if you don't just get mad at me at
least like yell at me but great guy and
we had great experience so when it came
to the day the laughter died
so me and Rick put out hit albums and
this is right like I think after dice
rules these are high-powered comedy
albums
to sell millions of copies
so
this you'll like mitzi's involved in
that this is great
so um
me and Rickett talking and I go you know
you know how much I love going on late
at night and just you know no reaction
because that time my career got made I
was always like one of the last few
whacks at night at The Comedy Store you
know of course are the kind of stuff I
did so there's you know people sitting
quiet you got a drunk in the front with
his head on the table and you got four
people that are just too tired to leave
you've had those sounds oh yeah you know
and I go I want to do like the ultimate
late night set
you know and he sort of had the same
thought process like we just go
unsuspecting crowd you know and this is
like you would say at the height of
doing the Arenas you know craziness
surrounded me at that time it was like
the Lady Gaga of stand-up comedy you
know and now I just want to go up in
front of a few people
with no notes with no idea of what the
album's gonna be
and we we do three nights at danger
fields and it winds up the double CD the
day the last that died okay
and I'm just loving it you know the
silence the smoke you could hear me
smoke
you know people walking out you know we
and we didn't cut any of it you know
like I said keep it in there you know
it's great you know I really got angry
you know at this family that came in see
this will lead to it could set me up for
Saturday Night Live to tell you stuff
but so that this family comes in these
real [__] out of town is from
I don't know
Midwest Bible Belt you know whatever
they were but they were all wearing the
same coat in the same hat with the with
the ball on top
two daughters mother father now sitting
in the front
and the more I got into them the more
the father left
and I got angry at that because I'm
going this guy I would imagine
in my mind that this guy really looks to
[__] around with his daughters they were
old enough you know they were like I
don't remember the ages but I don't know
young 20s late teens
and I'm going why is this [__]
laughing when I'm doing this instead of
going
they cut it out
because I know if I was sitting there
with my two daughters in some Comics
some [__] on stage is going so you
like to have her on your lap or whatever
I said on the album you know I look at
the guy I go walk away from me my family
well there's a problem you know that's
how I would get this guy's laughing and
I'm angry about it you know so the more
he would laugh the more I would go after
this [__] but there's also no
laughs that's the part I did enjoy the
actual
Silence of the room or somebody walking
out and yelling what's that there's a
famous One lying on that you're about as
funny as a glass of milk you know the
album better than me which is ridiculous
why would you not that's it I love that
album